new light is being shed on an
immigration case that turned into an
issue in the presidential election last
year the Justice Department released an
arrest warrant for Jose Ynez Garcia
Zarate the decision came after a San
Francisco jury acquitted the
undocumented Mexican of murder in the
2015 killing of Kate Steinle sirata was
found guilty of illegal possession of a
firearm John Blackstone reports on how
the decision is again is against raising
is again raising questions about
so-called sanctuary cities such as San
Francisco a day after Jose Ynez Garcia
zarada was found not guilty in the
murder of Kate Steinle he now faces
deportation and potential federal prison
time for violating his probation an
amended arrest warrant which was
unsealed Friday says Zarate must be
returned to federal custody and
transported to Texas for sentencing but
it's unclear whether Zarate would serve
his time in the Steinle case before he's
turned over to the feds he faces up to
three years behind bars when he's
sentenced Thursday's verdict has also
reignited an intense national debate
over immigration and sanctuary city
policies like San Francisco from day one
this case was used as a means to foment
hate Garcia's errata had been recently
released from the San Francisco Jail
when his attorneys say he accidentally
shot Steinle in 2015 under sanctuary
city policies he had not been turned
over to immigration authorities
President Trump
referenced the killing throughout his
campaign another victim is Kate Steinle
gunned down in the sanctuary city of San
Francisco the president weighed in on
the verdict on Twitter Friday accusing
top Democrats of being weak on crime and
calling surah tees exoneration a
complete travesty of justice san
francisco city officials have pushed
back against criticism vowing to stand
by their so-called sanctuary city policy
or CBS this morning Saturday John
Blackstone San Francisco